all right
let's
do it
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to y'all
[Music]
is
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
riffing with griffin we doing it once
again live
[Music]
um
i don't know
casual ass week i'm doing the podcast
live again i have bigger plans but you
know things happen
so welcome to riffing with that
[Music]
all right you know it is what it is
welcome back guys welcome back to
roofing with griffin let's just do some
business right off the top uh thank you
for subscribing so please make sure you
subscribe share hit the notifications
tell people you know if you really like
the show tell people about it and tell
them why because we're trying to grow
the show
um excuse me uh and also you can also
catch me every day on twitch eric
griffin gaming so make sure you follow
me there on twitch eric griffin gaming
i'm always live on that so come check me
out i started playing this game eldon
ring so i'm playing that i went back to
destiny and i still play call of duty
all the time so if you want to see me
doing that so make sure you check me out
on that and once it again thank you for
subscribing and sharing and all that
kind of stuff so welcome
casual episode i don't even have an ad
this week um
yeah well so what's up guys uh first let
me say thank you for everybody for
listening and like last week
last week was great because i had a lot
of great birthday wishes so i want to
thank all the people that gave me good
birthday wishes last week you know
ab abroar
uh i can't even pronounce some people's
names and that's what i think that was
everybody was getting me out about the
batman episode
pattison robert pattinson i don't know i
kept saying patterson
but you know who the hell i was talking
about
but i guess i wouldn't want to be called
eric griffey air graphene
or irek refined
i get it you know what i mean but it's
just one of those weird names so thank
you natasha yee and
uh martin castaneda
and um um all the people that gave me
good birthday wishes i really appreciate
that uh you know 50s
feeling it it is what it is
you know i had to i go to next health so
i just went to next health today
uh to get some of the pelleting you know
i've been doing some hormone stuff to
keep my testosterone high and it's been
going good and i like uh actually when i
started doing my workout shout out to
hydro since i got a hydro rower and i've
been working out like a
minimum three times a week but when i'm
home during the week sometimes i'll do
it every single day you know i just i
try to get a minimum of two miles in
uh but it ends up being something like 4
000 meters and then you know different
things that they want you to do on the
rolling machine and i've really been
feeling great
i've been feeling great um
you know i just i just think that
there's something about just
having some movement and exercise in
your life along with diet is just gonna
you know changing my world
so you know
it is what it is actually i gotta take
my ice pack out
so yeah um
been doing that and that's good so again
like i say thank you for all the
birthday which wishes spooky tooth
uh all the guys all the people that gave
me good birthday wishes tom that's all
it says is tom and adrian kaye and
and yeah just everybody thank you for
listening to the podcast too on apple
apple
podcast or wherever you get your podcast
and you're listening to it right now i
appreciate you guys for listening to the
podcast too so
excuse me um
if you watch king and sting you'll see i
have this same shirt on because we tape
king of the sting on tuesdays so i went
i had to go do a episode today
and then i just came right i had to go
get my car
detailed which my car is out at the shop
getting detailed and i'll tell you about
that right now and so i have the same
shirt on that i had in that so you know
behind this behind the curtain of how
podcasts work so
you know is what it is
um so let me tell you
about why
i had to get my car detailed
so some people always ask about where's
wiggy what happened to wiggy wiggy's
still around man i just
with my traveling and schedule and i've
been doing the episodes live there's
just there hasn't been a need and then
you know he's busy he was doing music
because he he does music videos and
direct music videos and he's just like
busy and we're both kind of like we're
actually sometimes not a good fit
because we're both procrastinators and
you know it's just it's weird but
anyways i hadn't seen him in a while
rachel's out of town so i was like yo
man you want to what you doing let's
talk about stuff and while we go get
some dinner i'll treat you to dinner you
know what i mean so
i took we went to like a really nice
place you know i took this [ __ ]
to boa steakhouse in santa monica
because i was go i would go by myself
like i i like to eat well
so
and and i went to this other steakhouse
for my birthday when i was by myself in
west palm beach and it wasn't good like
it was i was up really upset because you
know you go to like a fancy steakhouse
you want the [ __ ] to taste good and this
was like i'm not gonna say where it was
but it just was like
excuse me some old regular it was just
regular and i was like i was
disappointed
so i said oh i want to go do this and
then like rachel's out of town cause her
and i we went to a nice place just her
and i
um
we love going to uh what's what's it
called in a century city mall um
del frisco's that's our spot i love del
frisco shout out to them
so i was like you know i want to get it
i want to get another steak so i said uh
let's go so he's like he comes over i
hadn't seen him in a while you know
i love talking to the kid you know and
then he like we go so we get there
you know what i mean we i get a steak
he'd get a steak right
and then you know we shared us
we split a salad
as an appetizer and and we shared the
sides
but i got my steak medium well that's
how i like my steak medium well
and sometimes i hate when they overcook
it
because then it becomes well done but if
you ask for medium well and say they
undercook it it actually comes out
just right
well he asked for medium rare okay which
is like bananas to me but hey whatever
all right
we eat then we like about to leave
you know
and he's like
he's like oh
you know i'm like what's wrong with you
and he was like you know he didn't
really say anything you know he just was
like i don't know you know so we get in
the car and he's just he has some
leftovers too he didn't even finish and
so he's all this in a paper bag so he's
just all like uh you know and i'm like
he's like
i'm like oh [ __ ] so i'm trying to rush
back to my place because i'm like what's
going on like he i didn't even think
that he was gonna like be sick sick you
know what i mean but he was like
actually feeling it you know
next thing you know we three minutes
away from my place and this [ __ ]
throws up
okay just like all in the the paper bag
that his food is in and it's like
ugh
and all you can smell is the caesar
salad and like
in in his guts you just smell wiggy's
guts it was just wiggy guts all over the
place and he's like you know i'm like oh
no that's something like you know i have
a plastic bag in the in the back seat of
trash that i was gonna throw away so i
grabbed that i said well here's a
plastic bag okay
then he lifts up the plastic bag to put
it in the paper bag and then it just
busts
all over the floor all over his seat all
over him
and in my damn car
so now you know now we're rushing home
and it's just like you know like i said
internal caesar sally guts
all over the place with his little [ __ ]
stomach because he can't handle his meat
[Laughter]
old punk ass can't handle his meat
you know what i mean and so
expensive ass dinner too by the way so
half the dinner is now on the on on my
freaking
car floor you know what i mean and so uh
we get back and then i had to go
upstairs like he was like and he was
like so apologetic like oh my god your
car but so i get like the paper towels
and he like
you know he's like
trying to clean it up wipe it up and
it's just a nightmare okay
so i you know he did the best he could
and and he did a fabulous job now and he
really was guilty about it so i grabbed
some baking soda and by the way life
hack
if you have like like especially if you
spill something on a rug let's say you
spill some some wat even some wine on a
rug anything that's gonna stain get some
baking soda right away pour the baking
soda like just be generous with the
baking soda all over the spill
because what will happen is the baking
soda will suck up all of the um
that liquid then you let it dry and you
can just vacuum the the baking soda
right up and then and it just takes care
there'll be nothing there it's actually
pretty dope so i go get baking soda
thinking about this and then we get some
like i have some like
spray some like you know cleaner and he
cleans up the best he can but it's a
like it's a funk box okay and so i put
the baking soda and just leave it
so today
yesterday i didn't have time so i got in
the car today and it just was like oh my
god it just it smelled like a
you know
it just smelled like in internal wiggy
guts okay so if this if this was like a
smell
it's just nasty ass
smell
so now i have to get
um
i have to get like
oh thank you future nobody i appreciate
you man you need to why are you sending
me money and you send me so many great
great artwork this guy man
future nobody everybody he's a dope dude
so i um
i so now i just took it to so i would i
did king of the sting and then i had to
go do this medical stuff and then i'm
headed home and i was like i can't take
this anymore because i have to drive far
tomorrow so i was like i went to this
place and you know then it was like you
know you it's better to make an
appointment when you're getting car
detailing because they're all like well
you know we can't you know we can't get
it to you right it's going to take two
three hours so i said all right so i
left my car i ubered home to do the
podcast for you guys and you know for
myself so i'm doing the podcast and
waiting for my car to get detailed so it
is what it is
so shout out
shout out for uh you know
you know
little [ __ ] bitch-ass stomach
you know just make sure you go to just
go to wiggy's instagram and just
comment on his pictures like heard you
got a little bitch-ass stomach
[Laughter]
like it just you know there's just
something about like the violation
when somebody when you spill something
stinky in your car or somebody vomits in
your car it's just like the worst i
remember when i was a kid i remember
when i was a kid and i was like it was
my birthday and my mom was like taking
us to like magic mountain that was like
one of my favorite things to do for my
birthday so like i'm like shout out to
my mom because she like the car broke
down so she rented the car because she
knew i wanted to go to magic mountain it
was my birthday and when you're a kid
you don't care about life
you know you told me you were going to
take me so we get to but we like had
some like sugary i was a mess so like we
tried i'm in the front seat and we drive
into magic mountain and i'm like oh
stomach was starting to like be like
what's going on
sure enough i got sick so i had to roll
down the window and then like i
i was like i rode out the window and i
just like vomited outside the car and
then the vomit just went right back in
the car to the back seat all over my
friend
oh never forget that you know
ain't nothing like when you vomit when
you're a kid because when you're a kid
like you don't even know you're gonna
vomit like your your body is so like
ready to go you know that you're just
like
you're you just go until you're sick you
know what i mean
just
just you go
and then like
when you're a kid you get sick like pam
like instantly you don't even you know
it don't even sneak up on you oh thank
you sincerely yours you guys stop it
with the snap with the super chats but
you know it is going towards getting the
car getting the car detailed so i
appreciate it
you know what i mean like you you like
even you guys in chat if you remember
your worst
put it in the comments
your worst vomiting story
it was like oh man the worst time i ever
got sick like recently this is the worst
ever ever ever i just started dating
rachel we've been dating for
like a significant amount of time that
we were serious but it still was new and
fresh
so
it was christmas she's jewish
i was like let's go to
costa rica i've never gone to like costa
rica or a place like that on a romantic
trip
i'm getting serious with her and i'm
like let me just you know what i mean so
we go to costa rica and i remember like
the the night we went had some whatever
food and i started i was feeling
something i was like ooh
what's going on and then her and i kind
of got into like a fight it's just like
one of those dramatic like it's nonsense
fight but then i was like but babe i'm
not something's up i'm not feeling well
and then i had to like i was like oh man
and then it just overcame me and i got
up and i had to i didn't have nothing so
i had to use my
oh
you know right in my hands had to run to
the bathroom and then she was like
grossed out you know what i mean she was
like getting mad at the time she was
being super selfish she was like you're
ruining the trip
and then like
oh but it was just both ends y'all just
the worst i had food poisoning like i've
never had in my freaking life
you know what i mean like the worst food
poisoning i ever had in my life oh my
god guys
salty jay thank you so much my goodness
you guys are just you guys are fantastic
honestly
honestly fantastic um
[Music]
man i need to bust out my new
you know what i have some i have some
music
i have some music that people have sent
me
you know what i mean and i normally
i normally don't
do this
i haven't done this in a while
but
i mean i appreciate all these super
chats so
all you super chat people
you get a little bit
you get a little bit of
oh this is one of these beats that
people send in
thank you
oh oh thank you for the super chat oh oh
oh
that's how we do it
thought you knew it
on stream
[Music]
[Music]
thought he was a dude
in my car
thank you for the super chat
future nobody for this rap sincerely
yours
salty j
that's how we do it
all right
quick freestyle for all the super chats
thank you very much
so um
yeah so we all in costa rica and i'm
sick for like two days
it's the worst i was like i don't even
know how rachel and i survived it like
as her couple because it was like i was
so mad at her for how she was acting she
was mad at me because you know this is
this great vacation and i remember i'm
like so sick and she's like
she goes and she orders room service
while i'm sick and she's like i hear her
on the phone
yes can you send like it's like
it was like all-inclusive so she's
ordering food having a good time and i'm
just like dying
from both ends
but we survived it and now we're getting
married
but that was one of the first time
that was one of the first times i'd ever
been like that sick ever like like i've
never had food poisoning like that
usually my stomach can take everything
but i had something some kind of bug you
know and i think wiggy just like it was
the medium rare steak by the way i
didn't go back and say that i think that
because he ordered his steak medium rare
and it was undercooked i think he had
like some bacteria or something and that
just did not go well so
you know what i mean that's how that
goes y'all that's how that goes out in
these streets
so
um
yeah it's like casual i'm doing the
podcast on tuesdays now because i
thought it would be
you know easier
because like you know i'll be traveling
and coming home and still i still messed
up today and got the podcast out super
late that's why it's like three like
four o'clock on a frickin
four o'clock on a tuesday and i haven't
put the podcast out i had somebody else
send me some some beats and by the way
if you if you're a musician out there
you want to send me send me some
uncopyrighted beats if you have some
beats
and then you know i'll use them on my
gaming channel and i'll use them on the
podcast when people send me
when people send me super chats i gotta
find this one guys this one guy sent me
like because i haven't saved them in my
folder yet
you know but uh and i'm looking for him
on the fly so excuse me for that oh here
we go is that it right there nope that's
not it
um
yeah cause like i still have all these
beats from like back in the day when i
first started the podcast like a year
ago people would send me like so many
fantastic
stuff and i just i use it on i use it on
the pocket on my gaming channel all the
time so anytime i win a game a match
you know anytime i win a match i use i
use a beat to like you know freestyle uh
whatever you know i'm no free i'm i'm no
freestyle rapper but you know you guys
get you get you get to just
uh you as you can see you know how i am
when i when i just did that what i just
did
but anyways let's talk about
can i find this where is this i can't
find it whatever guys but let's talk
about some stuff that's going on in the
world right now
um
so something that was like really on my
mind was like uh oh actually even before
i do that let me just say thank you for
the comments like all the comments on
the batman episode so everybody just
sent me comments i was reading some of
the comments and like one of the
comments that people kept saying is like
he's only year two he you know he's he
just started being batman he's not gonna
be a good detective and what i'm saying
is like i feel like he was a not just
that he wasn't a good detective he was a
terrible detective like i don't think he
should be terrible
and they did sell us on that like a lot
of the pre-pre stuff about the movie was
gonna be like they're gonna show
batman's detective skills um i don't
know i just feel like
can he get one win
like just like one win in that process
with the riddler he didn't get one win
with the riddler not one like he needed
help the whole way and it was lucky help
he had the voicemail from catwoman and
then the cop who like oh yeah my my
father does
rugs and that's how he figured out that
stuff was under the rug so
i just i don't think
i don't think that you know he was that
great and if you think about it later
you go hey how come he didn't like
figure out hey what is this tool used
for you know what i'm saying like what's
that tool used for he didn't even think
to even ask that i don't know i just
feel like i get that he's like new and
young he's trying to figure out the
whole how to be batman it's only year
two but i feel like he deserved a win or
two you know what i mean he deserved a
win or two in that process and he never
got not one
you know you know he just he got helped
the whole way and i just i didn't like
that
i was gonna go watch uncharted but i
haven't seen it yet because it just you
know i haven't been really out of town
to go see movies oh and i should talk
about being going out of town i'm going
to lol comedy club which i got to change
that on my website so look out for me in
lol comedy club in san antonio and i'm
coming to the houston improv in apr both
of those are in april i believe but you
can see it on my website eric
griffin.com all right so yeah um
billy xyz gave me a good comment about
you know he said michael keaton was his
top batman i disagree with that
a lot of people didn't took offense to
me saying that i like jared leto's joker
i liked it at the
one time at the end of the snyder cut
that's when i liked it i wish he would
have done that the whole time but he
didn't um
so there's that
uh and then this guy poop poop sock
that how you say poop socks said i think
your assumption that they wanted to show
batman as a great detective is false i i
completely and utterly disagree with you
there was a lot of stuff before the
movie came out that that's what they
were talking about there was websites
talking about it there was like you know
they're going to show that was that what
they were selling that he was going to
be a great detective so i disagree with
you on that
um joshua
subia sabia whatever i think you made a
lot of valid points and it's refreshing
to be able to debate and have an open
discussion that's what i'm trying to do
on riffing with griffin let's have an
open discussion so if you have some
thoughts and feelings you can put them
in the comments i will look at them but
if you're just going to be a rude
[ __ ] like move on move on with your
life nobody cares
um what else so yeah so anyways thanks
for all the good comments on um
on the youtube channel okay
um
so that that was pretty cool that was
pretty cool
so all right and so
so
i want to talk about this desean watson
so deshawn watson if you don't know who
that is he's the houston texans he was
the houston texans quarterback
he wanted to be traded and then
all of a sudden
out of nowhere it seems because he also
had he was also a quarterback with like
a really good reputation
you know he had a really good reputation
and
next thing you know he he has these 22
allegations against him
um that he was had some sexual
misconduct at massage parlors
so like 22
women are like now you know suing him
are they for i guess they were trying to
i don't listen i don't know all the
details of the case so please don't
like get on me i'm just i'm just i'm
just talking about it like and i'm doing
it live so i'm just talking i got the
thing up i'm trying to look for stuff as
i'm talking about it but i just i'd have
some thoughts about where it's at now
that's what i'm just trying to get some
of you caught up so you know what i'm
talking about as i'm talking about it so
you know um
and then he
you know so then so then there's a there
was criminal investigation
and then there's 22 civil lawsuits
against him i believe or this there's 22
ladies involved in this lawsuit
and so
and then he wanted to be traded and so
now because of it
he was on the i guess the commissioner's
exempt list and that's a list where
you're like not playing
you can't play even though you're still
getting paid so he didn't play all last
year and he was still getting his salary
which was like exorbitant salary
something like 40 million dollars or
something you know
excuse me
it was just a really big salary so he
wasn't getting paid so now
cut two now
there's a grand jury
to decide if there's going to be a
criminal uh trial
and they come to say that there's
there's um
no
there's not enough evidence
to proceed with a criminal trial
so now it's that's done so there's no
chance of him
getting tried or convicted of any crime
so now it's just a matter of
are these ladies gonna prove in court if
he goes to court
that
something happened and they deserve some
compensation
okay so first thoughts
as you all think like
22
like you hear that number and you go
22. so there's a thought you know if you
want to be somebody if it was one two
and this happens a lot like it happens
more than you think that professional
athletes
get accused of things
that are true or untrue
and then they just kind of like brush
they just settle
and some of them settle and they don't
settle out of guilt man sometimes it's
just like it's the easier way
path of least resistance
if you're going to have to go to if
somebody's putting you through all this
and you have to hire a lawyer and you
have to go through the trial and you
have to go like all the the things that
it's going to bring up a lot of these
type of high-profile people decide all
right what are they asking for and then
they figure out a settlement and then
boom and it's a stupid tax that's what
it really is it's a stupid tax
like maybe you went out with somebody
you didn't really know things got out of
hand like in a sense of like you know
you you uh went further than either one
of you should have gone and the person
turns around and says i didn't want to
do that or whatever the situation is and
obviously there are situations where
somebody takes advantage of their power
and they go too far you know what i mean
like i'm not i'm not saying that you
know everyone's always lying or
everyone's always guilty i'm not i'm not
saying that but i'm just telling you
that there are many cases where
these things come up they get accused of
something it feels shady even when you
hear the circumstances and you go what
is this this don't seem like right and
then they just settle out of court just
to like get rid of it okay and obviously
some people are like well that's an
admission of guilt
i think it's case by case okay all right
so you have those that happens
but this is 22.
so you're you know you know what i mean
so you hear that number and you go well
damn if is it one massage therapist two
when it gets to two you're already like
what if it's three you're like well god
damn dude but 22. so obviously the dude
got it this is the dude got issues like
if he goes to massage parlors he could
just be addicted to it people got sexual
fetishes and addictions he's at a
massage parlor you're getting touched
you're naked i go get massages all the
time i mean your butt ass naked man and
it's like you know
you know sometimes it gets weird whether
you wanted to or not sometimes i mean
i've been in a situation of massages
where i'm like ooh this is like
this is borderline and getting
inappropriate like and what do you say
what are you supposed to do so i mean
you know it's you know what i mean and
there are guys that go for that specific
reason you know they don't even want the
massage you just like get to that happy
ending you know what i mean so he's
obviously somebody that enjoyed that
because i don't think he's refuting that
i mean i don't even really know if he's
refuting that or not
uh but they're coming off like the dude
forced them to do things and you know
they're saying things like that but it's
like
here's my thought
22 people are saying something similar
about him
that's not enough corroborating evidence
to
[Music]
um go into a criminal investigation so
so that gave me some pause
because
i know that like you don't always need
um evidence
like if it's one person you need
evidence sometimes you need someone to
corroborate your story then that's
enough
to for them to proceed forward
so you would think that 22 people are
saying the same story about someone and
there was no
no evidence not one of these testimonies
are enough
of the 22 people to go in to to have
some criminal investigation so that let
me that that gave me some pause all
right i did that gave me some pause um
but still you know people should feel
what they feel it's like it's no it's no
shade on the the alleged victims uh you
know
it obviously
something went on that's what you can
infer from 22 people so you know what i
mean it's like you know so what do you
do right like what are we supposed to do
as an outsider looking in that's the
question okay so now we're sitting here
waiting to find out and he claims he's
innocent
which is the reason why they haven't
settled out of court already
i think
i think they should have just i think he
should have just settled out of court
because it feel because he can never get
his reputation back you know
and and i'm and and and i agree with
this take from marcellus wiley from
speak for yourself shout out to
marcellus and that show i love that show
him and emmanuel acho on fox sports but
i heard him saying the same thing he was
like he can't get his reputation back
like his reputation is tarnished forever
when you search deshaun watson on google
this thing is going to come up forever
so he's never going to be innocent there
are people who are always going to
believe that he did something wrong no
matter what he does
unless
something comes out unless these women
themselves come out and say
the lawyer or someone put us up to this
and he never did anything wrong and even
still there will be people
that will that think that he's guilty
okay
so what i'm saying is if you can never
get your reputation back what's the
point of going to court like it's not
gonna save him
he might as well get rid of this so it
could be in his past because now this
looming 22
i don't know how many actual civil i
think it's like seven or eight cases but
22 people are attached right so we'll
see
because then if he settles
what does that mean if he settles
uh you know like then it just goes away
and that's the end of it and he just
hoped he doesn't make the same stupid
mistake again
meaning like
if he did something wrong he should 100
be punished for that
you know and obviously there are people
in this situation the women involved who
feel something was wrong and it's a [ __ ]
and you can't always
you know prove that in court
like him not being found him them not
finding enough evidence to go to trial
doesn't mean he was innocent okay so
that let me just put that out there so
there's okay so anyway what am i talking
about this for
cut two
this is
happening right now
so i think that the nfl was waiting
about the criminal trial so once the
criminal trial is like boom boom let's
wash our hands there's no chance of him
getting arrested or being a trial nfl is
back in business
he gets traded to the cleveland browns
for something like
a bunch of draft picks and he signs a
fully guaranteed
263 million dollar contract
now the question becomes
how do you feel about it
is this right or wrong
and like especially with the the
the
civil case still pending
i don't know guys
you know
i don't know what it feels like to be
you know a victim of this
sexual assault or you know you know what
i mean so i'm not going to sit here as a
man or just as someone that's never
experienced that and being a man and
trying to trivialize it or making it
like out like you know it's not
important because it is important so the
question we have right now is how does
the nfl look
how do the cleveland browns look how
does the sean watson look
because the optics of it are
that's it it's done
we're moving on with business regardless
of how it looks
and he and he still can be suspended
by the league he can still be suspended
by the league for just basically a
stupid tax like being involved in such a
ridiculous situation
guilty or not we're going to suspend you
but then this contract is set up where
it's a five-year contract
in year one he only makes a million
dollars for the year and then the rest
of the contract is where the money is
right
so if he's suspended this coming season
his his agent set it up where
he ain't gonna lose money he's only
gonna lose
part of a million dollars
so that looks fishy the optics of it
just don't look good that's all i'm
saying
just the optics don't look good and so
you have a situation now where like
either
the nfl is saying hey
we just care about winning we care about
getting the players on the field
and we don't care about nothing else
the only thing that's going to really
affect change is the bottom line like 40
of nfl fans are women so if this 40 and
not just the women like men too okay
like if if there's a percentage of
people who decide hey this doesn't look
good this you should not have this guy
in the like he he needs to be
significantly suspended you know like if
he like like he didn't play all of last
year if they want to count that as his
suspension and he has to pay back the
money that he made last year as part of
his suspension then maybe i'll be fine
with that you know like if he has to pay
back all the money he made last year of
his 30 million dollar salary because he
was still getting paid and then that
counts as his suspension then boom then
we're good because he had a year
suspension but if they suspend him for
like seven games
and he only loses seven times sixty
thousand you know uh
how does that look does it just do you
do you feel icky about it i want you to
tell me in your comments you know like
do you feel icky about it do you feel
like well dan did he get away with
sexual assault and we just are like
moving on with it and like whatever and
then like what happens with these like
civil cases like if he goes to trial
with the civil cases and they all get
thrown out we're good we're done
wipe your hands with it if a jury trial
of however the civil cases work
because you don't even have to
prove like oj was convicted in civil
court you get what i'm saying like it's
the burden of proof is a lot lesser that
you need it's civil so if he goes to
civil court and all the cases are
dropped then
hey you know what he won you know what i
mean he proved that he was right he said
i didn't do anything wrong and they
couldn't prove it if i did or not right
so then it's like we move on with our
lives and we're like all right well that
was a tough situation that guy went
through but let's say he goes to trial
and then they go yeah no no we find you
guilty
you we have enough evidence to find that
you should be paying these people x
amount of money
then
like how we gonna feel then
i don't know it's in limbo it's kind of
up in the air and i'm just honestly
saying i don't like how it makes me feel
um you know what i mean
i just i don't like how it makes me feel
so i'm just curious just to see like how
you know you guys feel about it you know
and we could talk about it in chat and
it's like listen guys i mean
you know it's a new it's a it's a
i always say nuance but this ain't even
a nuanced thing this is like one of
these things where it's like
it's like
you know again 22 people are saying a
similar thing they don't know each other
i don't know if all 22 like i would
think the first nine
and then like if maybe some people
jumped on because that's what people do
you know especially if you know you're
gonna be making money who knows right
but that's still a significant amount of
number to be like at the very least
there's some stupidity that went on here
like what was he doing you know
so
again
that's how i feel about it right now
again it just it it does make me feel it
does make me feel something and is that
going to be enough is there going to be
enough people who are going to be like
uh i'm kind of turned off by this like
when they announce his name and then
they they boo him like you know maybe
some women are going to maybe women do
be like yeah we're not going to come to
the game i think if it's if it affects
the bottom line like that then that dude
they're gonna make a different choice
they're gonna be like no no i'm sorry
you can't play anymore because you know
our fan base is saying they don't like
this you know i mean that's what
happened with donald sterling guys
donald sterling was notoriously racist
for years
he had cases against him for uh you know
misconduct not misconduct but like you
know racial and some racial [ __ ] about
his
uh uh buildings that he owned and you
know
uh
how people he wouldn't let people stay i
mean he he was notoriously racist for
years they didn't care he was he still
owned the team nobody said anything
the moment those big corporations were
like
yeah we pulling out of the staples
center that dude was gone
because it was affecting the bottom line
it's a nine ten billion dollar business
and and uh the these billion dollar
corporations that are involved they're
like yeah we don't like the feel of this
racist guy
right or wrong and they were like so you
do something or are we pulling out and
then the nba was like oop
you got to go
is that going to happen with the nba
and by the way
cleveland browns
i don't necessarily blame them
because it's not like cleveland was the
only team going out for him
there were like 17 apparently and i'm
just going off the sports talk shows
that i watch
there were at least 17 teams interested
in in him so they had all the leverage
that's why they got this fantastic fully
guaranteed the first year safety bubble
of only a million dollar deal you know
what i mean so if it wasn't gonna be
cleveland it was gonna be someone
so
and and they're all in this together so
anyways that's how i feel if there's any
ladies in the um
uh chat
watching if you have some feelings about
it i'd love to hear what you have to say
about it too
uh but yeah i just think this is going
to be a tricky situation coming up into
the to the year and and by the way too
let's say cleveland does great let's say
he plays fantastic is that good or bad
the optics of it is like if he's playing
great and no one cares
ultimately that feels like
morally bad you know what i mean let's
say let's say cleveland goes on and wins
the super bowl
does that wash away all of this it's a
tough thing man tough feeling but i
don't know i talk about the the weird
the the interesting sort of you know hot
button topics but this is one of them so
let me know what you think in the chat
and then i will for sure uh go back to
it after i see some good comments and
then you know we can uh start start the
discussion over again but
anyways guys so that's that
that is
that
now i wanted to talk about
on a lighter note
um this show upload on
amazon prime
um upload on amazon prime and my girl
zainab johnson is in the show and she is
doing just a fantastic job on the show
upload is dope it's a man is able to
choose his own afterlife after his
untimely death by having his
consciousness uploaded into a virtual
world
okay so that's the the concept and
upload is one of those really great
concepts
that they executed pretty good i think
it's a pretty good execution it could be
a it could be better but it's still
worthy of watching and it's a pretty
good
execution of this idea that you know
when you die your consciousness is
uploaded into a computer and then like
now you can like live your arrested you
know you can live forever in this
computer world where you have like but
the company that runs it you know
they're making money off of your your
debt your family is still paying for you
like your family has to pay for like
like in the computer world you know
there's still a uh
there's still like a you know a
hierarchy of like the rich and the poor
you know what i mean so it's like it's
it's it's actually and that's what i
love about the concept that thinking
about like you know this like they're
monetizing afterlife and then that's
that's such a human thing to do you know
how how
how terrible we are when it comes to you
know just making money is the ultimate
thing so
yeah so upload is a it's a pretty good
show season one was pretty good and
obviously
you know so this guy dies he's a
computer guy and he and then and like
you know it turns into like a murder
mystery because it's like did he die of
natural causes or was he murdered and
it's like trying to find out why he was
murdered so on top of having this great
concept of
upload of like uploading your
consciousness that you know it's
surrounded by tv show stuff
tv show stuff so it's just a matter of
you know do you like that
do you like to follow this stuff and
it's only like 10 episodes eight or
eight or eight to ten episodes and
season one's already fully available and
then season two is available too and
it's one of those things where you don't
have to bend you can binge it
uh but it's you know it's it's pretty
good uh robbie ml andy allo
they're just i don't even know you you
probably recognize some of these people
but it's
um yeah it's actually a pretty it's
actually a pretty funny show the girl
she the girl right there she's she's
really funny in it it's playing like the
girlfriend who's like supporting her her
boyfriend while he's dead and it you
know it's like so they're still in a
relationship because he's you know he
he's not alive but he's like
his consciousness is alive so it's like
like like wha what is what does that
mean what does it make me i don't know
what it makes me feel like
it's like the question of like what is a
soul you know
like
who are we
you know what i mean like who are we do
you ever think about that you ever think
like
are we are
the sum of our memories are we our
emotions and feelings
our intentions all wrapped into one and
like what makes us who we are
what makes us
and if do you believe in afterlife do
you believe that there's a heaven or a
hell do you believe that we move on from
our lives and whatever your religious
beliefs or spiritual beliefs are
it's like what do you think about this
and and and what if we were close to
this sort of technology of like
uploading our consciousness into a
computer and living in the computer like
are we living we were living in this
computer for like
you know
and
like the sort are we reliant upon
electricity uh you know can can our
consciousness be backed up you know what
i mean can we be like turned on and off
like at what point
at what point
is
is having a body make us alive
you know because it's like when
somebody's brain dead their body's alive
and you know we turn the machines off
because we feel like they're not there
anymore or even in my case when it's
like you have a loved one who has
dementia
and alzheimer's and it's like they're
not the same person anymore and like you
know
like what what's happening right now
like who is this person
you know
uh it's like so much the physical
connected to the mental because like
when you think about something like
dementia it very much is something about
the
brain degeneration
and the fog that you feel and uh you
know how you how you can't you know you
can't function
the same way you did before and so
are you not the same person anymore
you know or is it just like you just
have a defect that if you could fix that
you're still that person i think that's
how we look at it too that's why you
know we still it's not like we just put
people down because they lost their
memory you know we're still like we know
that there's a thing that happened and
if that thing could be fixed they would
still be the person you know the our
loved one
just the technology is just not there
yet
so
i don't know
um
i just you know i just i don't know i
don't know like i would love to hear
what you guys thought
what what what your thoughts are in the
comments like
what makes you
who you are
is it your body is it like what's your
soul
you know because if you actually could
download your consciousness onto a
machine
are you still that is that still you
are you still that person
regardless of the body and if you were
able to put that consciousness into say
a robot
you know
would you is that are you now
is it still you
uh
i'm blowing my own mind right now i
don't even smoke weed
um
i don't know what do you what i mean
what do you guys think
you know like are you you know what i
mean like
like like
like how would you feel about that like
imagine like
imagine like you have to pay a fee to
keep your parents alive in a computer
and it costs you like you know 11 000 a
year or something that like something
that like there's a choice you make
where you're like oh we got to turn mom
off you know what i'm saying
you know but maybe the technology is in
a way that like you turn them off and
then when you turn them off they don't
even know they've been off you know what
i'm saying
until they see you and they're like oh
my god how long have you had me off
you're like well about 10 years babe you
know you're like what like
you know what i mean like
man it's tough
because you know what concept i was
thinking about like you know you think
about like 60 of sixty percent of uh
relation marriages end in divorce
and you think about what is divorce it's
like when you you don't like someone
anymore or like you've moved on from
each other emotionally and you just you
can't i think it really has to do with
like you can't live together anymore
that you can't be around each other
anymore like what what that the pain
that that causes you know and i thought
about this man uh this is when me
working on material this is one of these
concepts right here is that i think the
first time you got divorced your first
divorce was from your parents
that was the first time you uh felt
that feeling
because there's a certain point where
you and your parents just do not get
along anymore
your mom and dad from my case your mom
they want you to do a certain thing that
you're like i don't want to do that they
want you to like to study something in
school and you're like that's not my
passion and then it's like they're
they're hitting you with this like well
you know you can't stay out late you're
like i'm a grown ass like if you're
still living at home like over 18 you're
like i'm i'm 20. like i'm i'm going out
with my friends and i'm coming home late
and they're like now you're not in my
house and so that's the first because
after first your first divorce
your first divorce is when you go i'm
moving out
or i'm going to college or i'm getting a
job and i'm getting my own place
and then you really start not seeing
your parents as much anymore you don't
spend time with them as much anymore you
just don't see them they're not in your
lives in the same way so that's really
our first divorce because i think that's
what happens in divorce you know you
just kind of get sick of somebody you
know what i mean
anyways
anyways anyways i don't know that was i
don't know [ __ ] we got
i think we got weird today
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got weird on riffing with griffin
today but it is what it is i still love
it
make sure you guys subscribe
share i'm coming to san antonio so look
out for that san antonio and houston as
of when this comes out oh it's out now
so just take a look at my calendar at
ericgriffin.com check me out on twitch
i'm on twitch every single day at eric
griffin gaming so come check me out
there appreciate you guys
um
yeah this was fun
make sure you get in get into the
discussion if you'd like
you know let's have a community of of
you know where we can talk
freely respect them respectfully please
and you know i don't mind having a back
and forth about all the things we talk
about deshaun watson
uh you know
and uh this whole idea of like uploading
your consciousness into a computer so
make sure you check out upload i'm
giving uploads
i give it four woof
so there's uh so shout out to upload and
shout out to zainab johnson my girl who
was on the podcast make sure you check
out that episode so anyways guys thank
you for being here thank you for
listening thank you for watching we're
from with griffin and i appreciate you
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
you